Speaker 1: I'm going to play a voicemail
from this very insistent troll, Troy York.
Now, some of you might say that rings a bell. Troy
York. Where do I know that name? Troy York has
been calling into the show and leaving voicemails
for years and years and years and months ago,
maybe even longer. I just stopped playing
his voicemails because they got so boring
and pedantic and pointless. You didn't like them?
I didn't like them. They didn't bring anything
interesting to the table. Recently, people have
been saying, whatever happened to Troy York? Well,
what happened to Troy York is that he still
leaves 2 to 3 voicemails a day, having played
his voicemail for months, maybe longer, but he
is insistently leaving voicemail after voicemail.
Half of them you can barely hear what he says. His
connections, the disaster, the background noise is
just infuriating. But I want to play one voicemail
just to show you this is really what happens when
your brain is completely scrambled on right wing
talking points and confusion and you're in a daze
where you completely lack any ability to think
critically or for yourself about anything. And
as often is the case, Troy York uses up the
full three minute max on our voicemail line.
Let's just see how far we can get through this.
But understand, this is your brain on idiocy.
Speaker 3: David Pakman more lies of the
corrupt mainstream media. Do their polling
continue to meddle and rock into the Pennsylvania
Senate election and continue? Lies and abuse
of polling is something that there needs to
be reckoning with. These polls mean absolutely
nothing and are meant to manipulate the votes.
They always favor the Democrats. Well.
Speaker 1: Right now, John Fetterman is
up for in polling in Pennsylvania and Ron
DeSantis is up five in polling in Florida.
So if we can't believe any of the polling, then
certainly on Election Day, both of the results
in those races should differ from the polling.
We'll be able to test that in just a few weeks.
Speaker 3: They are partizan in nature. They are
untrustworthy, they are deceiving, and they should
be declared and legal. Anyone with a brain.
Speaker 1: That's a really conservative
light touch, right, make polling illegal.
Speaker 3: Would ignore these polls. But naturally
you are like the scarecrow from the Land of Oz.
You do not have a brain that functions properly.
Your brain, Mr. David Pakman, is a butter.
Speaker 1: It's. It's not mayonnaise. It's butter.
Listen, I mean, polls are generally speaking,
pretty accurate. You know, you go back to 2020,
the polling going in had Biden like plus
five and Biden ended up winning by 7.2.
It's really pretty close in 2016. Let me see if
I get 2016. Trump Hillary, I'll get the exact
numbers for us. In 2016, the polling had Hillary
up three and Hillary won the popular vote by two.
Now, of course, we have this crazy system called
the Electoral College, and it led to Trump winning
the electoral vote. But the popular vote polls
said Hillary plus three. Hillary won by two. The
polling is, generally speaking, pretty accurate.
Speaker 3: You are so deranged with Trump
syndrome. You are so delusional with your
progressive, radical extremism. Yeah,
you can't even call these polls
for the horse manure that they are.
Dr. Mehmet Oz is by far the healthier,
stronger. More. More competent person.
Speaker 1: I can't speak to the comparison
between Oz and Fetterman on physical health,
but Oz is in way over his head. Veterans of really
brilliant guy, Harvard, lieutenant governor, etc.
Oz doesn't know. Up from down and left.
Speaker 3: From right. More competent.
Leader, then John Fetterman, who is a disgrace. He
is a scum. He looks like the average homeless guy.
He can't drive. He can't talk. He has no ability
to live a healthy lifestyle. He doesn't care.
And the man is. Morbidly obese. Unhealthy.
Speaker 1: I actually don't think. FITZSIMONS
Morbidly obese anyway. So that's Troy York.
That'll be the one voicemail for the year.
He'll keep calling in, you know, 2 to 3 times a
day. But for those of you who've been wondering,
it's still the same dribble. We have a great
bonus show for you today. Jenny Thomas,
the wife of Supreme Court Justice Clarence Thomas,
will be speaking with the House January 6th panel.
When and under what terms. We will discuss the
woman who falsely accused the black birdwatcher.
Remember that wacky story and then got fired. She
sued her ex employer and has lost the lawsuit.
We will talk about it. Many are calling it sweet
justice. I'm not calling it that, but many people
are. And the World Cup captains want to wear
rainbow armbands in Qatar. I have to tell you,
the rainbow armbands are fine, but the stadiums
were built by essentially slave labor. So this is
one of those things where, yeah, fine. But we're
kind of missing the forest for the trees. We're
going to talk about all of those stories and more
when producer Pat joins me on today's bonus show.
You can get instant access to the bonus show by
signing up at join Pacman dot com. And remember,
we have launched the new YouTube channel
pacman finance youtube.com slash pacman
finance. Subscribe free. The clips
are going up date. We'll see you then.